Welcome back to the day, the pattern show
Benjamin Dixon filling in for David while
he is away filming with Joe Rogan. Be sure
to watch his a episode with Joe Rogan later
on today. I'm also, this is my birthday. Oh,
turn up, turn up. Go to my youtube channel
and subscribe to my Youtube town eyes. Just
kind of a a birthday gift from me. This next
clip though, man, they've, Ruben, sir, um,
something's wrong with you and, um, the audience,
you'll understand what I mean by listening
to this clip. Take listening and it was totally
respectful. And then the media frames it like,
oh, even booty judge gets a standing ovation
at news, scary, right wing conservative, evil
Fox News. And it's like, well, I could tell
you that I've been traveling the country for
the last year and I meet conservatives and
right-leaning people everywhere who, no, I
disagree with them on several things.
Some of them disagree with, uh, very personal
parts of my life actually. And I find them
completely respectful and open and decent
all the time. And yet it's the people that
are constantly preaching tolerance and diversity
and telling me how wonderful they are and
how horrible everyone else's that are often
the most angry and mean and disrespectful.
So it's a weird situation we're in. So anyway,
so I'll talk to, uh, to Crowder about that.
Um, so let me place this in context. I actually
know the people, conservatives who disagree
with him on his sexual orientation. That mean
he didn't specifically say it there, but that's
what he's talking about. Like there's, there's
an entire, I mean, most conservatives, particularly
Evangelical Christians, people in the audience
for the places that he goes and speaks, uh,
you know, the intellectual, dark web is riddled
with people who believe the Lgbtq community
is going to hell.
Um, I know them because I, I, you know, I
come from the Baptist tradition, um, the black
baptist tradition, but Homophobia d knows
no race, right? It, homophobia doesn't discriminate.
Um, but, but the point is, is that I know
these people, and Dave, you know these people
and what you're doing is you're making excuses
for them. Much like Candice Owens, like you
and Candace Owens are, are, are, are, are
two peas in a pod in my birds of the same
feather flocking together. Uh, because both
of you have been willing to portray who you
are and what you are for a very, um, lucrative
paycheck because I, I'm sorry I couldn't even
watch. I could look not to psycho analyze
Dave, but I could watch when he said the word,
um, the phrase something a part very personal
to him that actually hurts him and you know,
and you know, when you think about like, you
know, maybe, maybe I shouldn't feel empathy
for him because you know, he's selling out
for money just like Candace Owen's.
But I felt a moment of empathy there because
really for his paycheck, he's having to go
on stage and speak to people who, no matter
what, think he's going to help. He has to
sit across the table from Ben Shapiro, Ben,
Ben Shapiro, and Ben Shapiro. You know, looking
at him saying, yeah, you're disgusting because
you're gay. You know, in his head thinking
that right. Or, or at a minimum, maybe, maybe
Ben Shapiro doesn't go that far. Right. But
at a minimum means going like, yeah, you know,
I believe that you shouldn't be able to get
married. Right. So take it, you know, so however
you know, however you want to wrap it bears,
people aren't not tolerable. They are in,
they, they, they have a level of intolerance.
That is the baseline. It is. It's like the
very, that's their starting point. And for
Dave Ruben to provide cover for them, uh,
particularly for something so personal to
him really just shows like how, how far money,
you know, honestly, I have no other way to
explain it except the checks must be great
over there.
I mean, I mean, look at the work that Candice
Owens is putting in right now. She's her,
her latest thing is undermining the documentary,
the documentary on Netflix, sorry, not a documentary,
but the movie on Netflix and title. When they
see us talking about the central park five
who were wrongfully accused, wrongfully imprisoned,
and finally exonerated of any crime. She's
doing the work right now to say that it's
all a lie. And the different credit part is
just using this movie to try to, to persuade
and to manipulate the feelings of black people.
All right? So you have people who are very,
very committed to their role and a sustaining,
uh, this white male Christian power structure
that Bill O'reilly described. Um, and this,
this Christian power structure that condemns
the Lgbtq community and the, and the white
power structure that, uh, that wants to maintain
its grip.
They have, you have people who are committed
to that, um, and their commitment to that.
I honestly think it just has to be because
they pay better over there on the right. You
know, the rest of us on the left, which both
of these people were, Dave Ruben used to be
on the left. Um, Canada's always used to be
on the left and you can't say that the justification
for them going over to the right was because
the left was intolerant. When you're going
over to a community of people who reject your
very existence. You can't say that, Dave,
but what you can say is that they pay better
on the right. Uh, that's all the time I have
for you today. Bonus show is coming up. We're
going to talk about a couple of great stories.
Um, and thanks for letting me hang out with
you, David. We'll be back soon. Be sure to
check him out on Joe Rogan's podcast. Take
care